hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
filter fume hoods expert insight on
improving your lab's green initiative
i am sabrina lemoos of labyrinth and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots
and brought to you by lab conco
to learn more please visit www.lanco.com
let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind everyone that this
event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click
send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for
at the end of the presentation if you
have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on the support tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab
located on the top right of the
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i now present today's speakers casey
fulmer
and the production specialist at laptop
corporation
and tennis crooks the director of green
fume hood technology at lebconko
corporation
for a complete biography on our speakers
please
visit the biography tab at the top of
your screen
casey and kenneth welcome our speakers
will now begin their presentation
hello everyone and thank you for joining
us for this presentation on filtered
fume hoods and improving your
your lab screen initiatives with
efficiency continuing to be
a point of importance in building design
and operation
one aspect of lab space as often
addressed first is the fume hood as it
can have a large effect on the hvac
system let's first take a look at the
different types of fume hoods
that can be found in many lab spaces
the first that we'll look at are the
ducted
now ducting fume hoods can come in
one of two sort of configurations
that would be the remote blower or the
built-in blower models
and what we're going to discuss first is
going to be the
ducted hoods the first one that we're
going to talk about the first
configuration we're going to talk about
is going to be the remote blower
configuration
this is the most uh most common type of
installation this puts the blower on
the roof or somewhere outside of the
building away from
the the fume hood in a remote location
hence the hence the type of
configuration that is that is titled
here
this also allows it to be a little bit
quieter than typical
because as i've as i've said it's far
away from the hood
another aspect to the remote blower is
that it can be
sized for duct length this includes
the total length of the duct the uh the
the 90 degree
bends or any other sort of uh
differences in your mechanical system
the benefit here is that
no matter what you have this this can be
properly sized
for a blower that's going to work for
your individual
fume hood setup they are also
um they're also very safe remote blower
puts the
entire duct run under negative pressure
and that means
that if there are any leaks or or seams
in the duct run all the air on the
outside of the duct is just going to be
sucked into the duct
and then exhausted through through the
building so you're not at risk of any
contaminants
getting into a lab space with a with a
remote blower
having a duct system under
negative pressure
next you can also uh challenge the
blower with a damper
this typically goes between the the fume
hood and the blower
um and that allows the the system to be
able to be
balanced easier and ensure that the
blower is operating within its
with when it within its most optimal
range
this is the setup of a typical setup of
a remote blower
you can see the zero pressure weather
cap that's on the top
that does two things it allows you to
reach
important height requirements or
discharge
for building codes as well as prevents
moisture or
precipitation from uh getting into the
blower and
in causing problems in in that sense so
that's just what they typically look
like i wanted to make sure i showed that
picture because
it's pretty beneficial to see this uh
see this
setup so next we're going to talk about
the built-in blower configure
configuration these are for simple
economical situations
and they're ideal for short straight
back runs and low toxicity applications
this is because it puts the blower right
on top of the fume hood
instead of on top of the building where
there's there's a lot of bends and
connections that need to be made
between the two they are generally
noisier
than remote blower installations as i've
said this
is a situation where it puts the blower
right at the outlet of the fume hood
instead of
really far away with a remote blower
that means you hear the blower
a lot better in this type of situation
the major downfall of a built-in blower
configuration
is the ductwork is under positive
pressure
so in in contrast to the remote blower
situation if there's a leak
or in a theme or or a crack in the duct
work
the the com the components the the
hazardous material that
is being dealt with in the future is
actually going to be pushed
out of those themes and into the lab
space
so that's why um all of this is is for
very
simple situations and setups because
um this it's not the safest uh
situation and straight duck runs uh are
a great way to
eliminate that type of um that type of
risk
so here are the associated costs with
with
abducted fume hoods and it mainly comes
in the form of the mechanical systems
this includes the ductwork itself
the exhaust fans the supply air
because if you are exhausting here you
need to make sure that you are supplying
enough air
so that the blower is is able to do its
job
and is not starved of air and as well as
the installation
so there is a lot that goes into the
ducted fume hoods that
that really need to be thought of on on
the front end of
the design phase and can
can cause some additional costs in the
in the build
so that was ducted fume hoods and the
other uh
the other form of humans that we're
going to talk about are the ductless
fume hoods
and these come in three types you have
the dh1
the dh2 and the dh3 setups
the ductus enclosures as the haste sound
have no duct which is a great benefit
and how they are able to do this is
through carbon filtration
so these these filters they capture
the the chemicals that are being brought
through them
and are able to recirculate clean air
into the lab space
most of the time your application will
need to be reviewed by the manufacturer
or someone of someone involved in that
to
make sure that it is applicable to what
you're doing in the lab
because not every application is is
suited for this i mean it's not a
substitute for
every hood there are a lot of benefits
that come with a ductless enclosure or
ductless fume hood
and one of them would be energy
efficient
as i stated before the duck or duck dead
fume hoods
will take air out of a building that has
been tempered
to uh to the comfort level of the lab
and is exhausting it out of the air
or out of the lab space then
air has to be supplied into the lab so
untempered air
has to be brought into the lab space
all of this takes money and to make sure
that uh the lab space of the air the
temperature the humidity all of it
remains constant with these ducted hoods
no air is exhausted so that is benefit
in that
it doesn't have as big of a a a burden
or doesn't present as a big
bigger burden on an hvac system
the next benefit is that they are
environmentally friendly
so ducted hood ducted hoods will take
the these chemicals
and hazardous vapors and fumes and
they'll exhaust them into the atmosphere
with the ductless enclosure you're
capturing those and then you're
you're taking these filters that have uh
that are that have been loaded with
these
hazardous materials and then you're
disposing of them
in a in an environmentally friendly way
next benefit is that they are very
flexible
they offer um flexible installation
uh they are able to be put in in
the the bottom building or the bottom
room of a very tall building where duct
work does not seem
plausible they're able to be put in a
building that is very
old in adding new infrastructure to the
buildings it would seem
very expensive and very labor intensive
so this added dimension of flexibility
is is a very big benefit of these these
ducted
fume hoods or ductless spearmints
as i've mentioned before there are
different types of
ductless hoods and that's in their bh
this is defined by fifa 9
and we're going to talk about the the
different dhs the dh1 the dh2 and the
dh3s next
first we're going to start with the dh1
the dh1
is is it has a filter it has a carbon
filter
but it's mainly for non-toxic or
nuisance odors
these also do not have a chemical sensor
so pretty much uh with a dh1
a ductless hood one anything that you
could do on an
open bench you can do in this hood
things like cover slipping or staining
so it's a very simple application
that these are these are designed for
next we have the dh2 hood or ductwork
hood
2. this hood meets all of the dh1
requirements
plus it has different types of filters
like an inorganic filters or ammonia
filters or
or different kinds of filters that you
can order based on what your application
requires
they can also handle manufacturer
approved toxic chemicals
often determined through a chemical
assessment form
another thing about the dh2 is that they
do have a
chemical sensor to detect breakthrough
unlike the dh1
these are not typical fume hoods though
as you can as you can kind of see
the sash here the opening just lifts up
instead of rising vertically and
seamlessly
there's also no room for service
fixtures such as
air gas electrical or anything that you
might need for the fuel
finally we will talk about the dh3
or the ductless hood 3. now this hood
meets all of the th2 requirements
plus and this is a big one it has a
secondary backup
filter and in particular the secondary
filter is identical
to the primary filter where the dh2
lacks in safety is that if you are using
the hood
and the the chemical breakthrough sensor
goes off
well you don't have a whole lot of time
to to clear out everything that's in the
hood
once that chemical sensor is going off
there's a potential that that
chemical or that vapor is escaping into
the lab space
with the dh3 it has a secondary filter
so even if that that alarm goes off you
still have your secondary backup filter
that will protect you for as long as it
takes to
decontaminate the hood or just get
everything out
and then ultimately replace the the
filters
these filters are of one kind and they
are built to handle acid solvents
and bases so again the difference here
between the dh3 and the dh2 is that the
dh3 just offers a new dimension
of versatility in that you don't need to
buy
multiple types of filters you're good
with the one
which is which is a big benefit these
hoods are also
the closest thing to a ducted general
chemistry
hood without being ducted to outside of
course these
as you can see in the picture it is a
full-size hood the sash
raises vertically instead of hinges and
there's also
there's also slots on the corner post
that allow for the installation
of service fixtures such as the air gas
and electrical
so now i wanted to go over a cost
analysis of different types of
fume hood configurations that will allow
you to decide
what is best for my lab the first one i
want to talk about is conventional view
hood
or a constant air volume situation
this is a this is a scenario where the
quantity of the
quantity of the exhaust air never
changes hence the name
constant air volume no matter where the
sash is
or the the components inside the hood
you're always exhausting the same amount
of air
for this situation or for this analysis
we're going to use
a specific exhaust volume of about 1200
cfm
this is pretty typical for a
conventional six foot bench top fume
hood
the initial cost on this would include
the
the fume hood itself as well as the
building infrastructure
the mechanical electrical and plumbing
and we're going to take a look at this
in a in a in a table format
you can see here the bench top hood
itself is about
hundred dollars the building
infrastructure adds on another twenty
thousand dollars
and then that which means the the total
capital equipment cost
is about thirty four thousand five
hundred dollars
out of all of the systems that we're
going to look at this is actually the
lowest
uh the lowest initial cost of of the
three
but you'll notice uh where it where it
has a low initial cost it it makes up
for
in the operating and maintenance costs
specifically
the makeup air column of having
nine thousand six hundred dollars it's
pretty large number
and equates to about twelve thousand one
hundred and sixty seven dollars
a year of operating and maintenance
costs
for that one hood it's a pretty
significant
cost especially when you see what the
next
couple of hoods will bring the next
analysis that we're going to do
is on a variable air volume fume hood
as the name suggests the the vav
means that the quantity of the exhaust
air actually changes to maintain
a specific base velocity so in the cav
what remains constant is the air
exhausted
and at vav what remains exhaust what
remains constant
is the phase velocity and in this
situation a typical six foot bench top
fume hood
will be able to operate on about 800
cfm average the initial cost for
this type of fume hood includes the
diffuse
itself very similar to the cav as well
as the building infrastructure
and finally it requires vav integration
with a with a whole nother system
this dud this does add a little bit more
of initial cost as you'll see
in this table we can see a comparison
here between the constant volume and the
variable air volume
hume hood in that it does have a larger
initial cost
um at the 39 500
about 5 000 more where it makes up for
that
is going to be in the operating
maintenance cost
and again drawing attention to the
makeup
air portion of this table it only
requires about
six thousand four hundred dollars and
this number
comes from taking about um a typical
uh cost for a fume hoods as per cfm
is about eight dollars per cfm
per year and that's where we're getting
these makeup air
numbers and the viv overall has about a
operating maintenance cost per year of 8
811 so there are significant
yearly cost um savings by
by going to a variable air volume system
and last we're going to look at the echo
filter beam mud
this is this is a ductless ductless
fume hood that we've sort of discussed
and in these hoods air is filtered
and then it's recirculated into the room
this means that the exhaust volume is 0
cfm much less the initial costs are
are very similar in that you do need the
fume hood
but where these hoods differ is that you
need to
order the these filters that go with the
fume hood
they are a separate cost
i wanted to look at a final cost
analysis with all three of these
put in one slide you can see that the
the total cost uh total capital
equipment cost for the
echo filter fume hood is actually less
than that of the variable air volume
hood at thirty eight thousand five
hundred and twenty dollars
approximately where this hood
really excels is in that makeup air
portion it has zero dollars
per year since you are recirculating air
in in in that eight dollars per cfm
does not apply here it does have a
little bit higher of maintenance costs
per year because
um you do have the filters associated
with the fume hood
but that 2093 dollars
of total operating and maintenance costs
per year
more than makes up for that so
that is that is the those are the the
types of fume hoods and
in ways that you can you can uh explore
to see what kind of uh ways you can
increase your your labs efficiency but i
wanted to
pass this on to to ken crooks with erlab
to explain
how these filtered fume hoods are able
to do what they do
and and perform the way that they are
all right thank you very much casey good
job appreciate that
so uh and thank you all to our viewers
uh for for your time today appreciate
that too
so we look at the filtration and we want
to know you know how does it work
obviously it's very important it's
pretty pretty simple how abducted fume
hood works but
how does a ductless hood especially a
dh3 the best of the best here so i just
want to work
logically this is a module or stack of
filtration
technology sitting on top of the
filtered fume hood
and starting at the bottom you first off
have a light
you know the hood users need to see what
they're doing of course
and then above that light will be some
pre-filters there are optional different
pre-filters we'll talk about that in a
couple slides
and then on top of that base module
would be a hepa filter
if you're working with hazardous powders
this is not required this is optional
and if you're not working with any
hazardous particulates or solids that
may become particulates
or high temperature acid use then you
would not need the hepa filter
and i'll talk about how we determine
when and where
on top of that would be the first carbon
filter so this is the one
i like to describe as doing all the
heavy lifting this is doing the chemical
adsorption day in and day out capturing
everything
generated within that hood and stopping
it at that point coming off
the outlet side of this filter will be
very clean air
and i'll talk about just how clean in a
minute amazingly clean
on top of that now would be the fan box
and so
just like casey was describing with the
remote blower configuration
or the manifolded vav system that has
the hood
up on the roof also this fan i'm sorry
has the fan up on the roof also
this fan is drawing air in through the
open sash
up through the cavity of the fume hood
capturing whatever is being evaporated
and vapors and whatnot used inside that
hood and then drawing it up through
the filtration column so again any
leakage
would be clean air into dirty not
contaminated air blowing out i mean it's
a very important point
and of course we comply with that also
and then lastly sitting on the very top
of this is that safety filter so after
the fan and
detection area that's also where the
sensors are located we place a redundant
fully redundant safety filter on top so
once we detect
molecular breakthrough of the primary
filter and we sound that alarm down to
the user
we also have that secondary safety
filter sitting on top to capture
whatever molecules did break through and
still return clean air
back into that laboratory very important
differentiation with the dh3
technology so how does it all look this
is a six foot wide fume hood you can see
if you count there's four modules of
filtration stacked up in there
and so this is our latest generation of
technology
and we're very excited to release this
with labconco and our goals were to
improve the filtration capacity
for solvents solvents and i have a slide
coming up on that solvents are the most
challenging chemical you can use they're
also the most common but we've got that
figured out not to worry
secondly ease of integration and
installation and so this lower image
here where the three
base modules are in descending order
there they basically are i have kids
you'll realize when i say this they're
like legos they interlock and they stack
and they distribute power and
communications both horizontally and
vertically
and self-configure so that was a huge
step in the right direction for
ease of integration and installation for
our dealers and making sure that you the
customer
are handed over a fully working filtered
fume hood
next up we wanted to improve the
detection by adding more sensors
so there's now an optional formaldehyde
sensor especially with the new
safety limits on formaldehyde exposure
it was very important to get a
specific sensor for that for the
applications that are using formaldehyde
you don't need it if you're not
also a relative humidity sensor in each
fan module
and the temperature sensor was already
there but we've now moved it up into
each
fan module also and then lastly adding
an anemometer so we'll measure directly
the face velocity and so that's the
speed of which that air is moving into
the fume hood it's a very good indicator
of safety though
containment testing is the final
indicator of that
we want to expand the communications so
you can still hardwire to your building
network
my kids back to them again my kids look
at me cross-eyed when i say hardwired
no come on now so we have wi-fi and
bluetooth capabilities also
so much easier connectivity there and
then the configuration and flexibility
there are different pre-filters you can
use
along with different sensors you can use
depending on your specific application
but as casey had also mentioned earlier
there's that one filter type that
handles acids bases and solvents
simultaneously in much higher volumes
than in the past
and simplified the maintenance also of
course with these improvements now it's
much easier to maintain these hoods
it was pretty easy before but it's a lot
easier and even now
so i mentioned solvents that first goal
we don't have to go through all these
details i don't want to bore you with
these but again
solvents because of their volatile
nature have always been the largest
challenge with chemical molecular
filtration
activated carbon type filters and so
we've done a few patented things here
that have really expanded our capacity
the example graph here is ethanol we've
increased it over 600 percent
uh the time before some level of
emission is sensed after the filter
and the first column on the graph on the
left i guess no
sorry middle column the one percent of
tlb
threshold limit value so that is a value
of
exposure that's allowed by the american
council of governmental industrial
hygienists
and tlv is not a short-term exposure it
is a lifetime exposure so eight hours a
day
five days of work week 40 years of your
life we're guaranteeing to you
detection and alarming at no greater
than one percent
of that already very low limit and so
how that plays in here
to our capacity these are capacity
increases before we sense
greater than one percent on the outlet
side of the primary filter
so just a real dramatic increase is
there still room for improvement heck
yeah if you're going to use diethyl
ether or cyclohexane
those are challenging and we'll want to
use those with
really a focus on limiting evaporation
so
very very small amounts and keep the
capped and covered when you're not using
it because it's got a low boiling point
it wants to evolve very quickly
i think you know that if you use them so
sensation
sensors and detection how is it we go
about that that one percent tlv exposure
that i just talked about
so first off there's an acid sensor in
there a whole suite of sensors
and a solvent sensor that are both
located up in the fan modules
so when that primary filter is no longer
at the efficiency that we all want it to
be at
we will detect that and we will alarm
meanwhile coming back into that
laboratory is
clean air no greater than one percent of
what you're allowed to be exposed to so
it could be 99
and you'd still be safe our guarantee to
you is less than one percent of that
just to be extra safe
additionally we have that optional
formaldehyde sensor we expect that to be
in about 15 percent of the applications
not too commonly used but when it is
it is and then that temperature and
humidity sensor also
and lastly that anemometer sensor all of
these add up to
safety if we're sensing it we're
detecting it
that's going to bring to you safety as a
hood user
but we need to know how you're going to
use these hoods as casey talked
i think very early on this isn't for
everybody
ductless hoods need to be approved each
and every time for your specific
application
so any reputable manufacturer will come
to you with a chemical questionnaire
and this is a lot more than just a
chemical list chemical list is a good
sort of go
no-go gauge place to start but we need
to better understand
not only which chemicals you're using
but how you're using them what is the
type of handling in this case we have a
couple recrystallizations some
evaporation thin layer chromatography so
forth and so on
then you tell us the chemical you tell
us what type of container it's going to
be housed in
that lets us know how much evaporation
may happen when it's open
you tell us is it primarily open or
closed what's the dilution or
concentration
the temperature vitally important to
know the temperature you're handling
that chemical at
how often do you do that handling on
average per month across a year
and then each time that you handle it
how many milliliters or grams depending
if it's a liquid or solid
and then for how long and so armed with
this level of information and detail
which
is a little bit of a work for your hood
users to complete but once it's done
it's done
we can go through there and be
absolutely sure that your application is
either approved or denied
and we typically deny about 30 25 to 30
percent of the applications each year
and if we don't approve it we won't let
it be sold it's really just that simple
safety first and then that report and
that approval
will go through everything provided by
the hood users and we'll from a safety
perspective at the very top of this
slide we'll look at
containment is everything you declared
to be used in this hood
going to be contained by the hood now
this doesn't matter if it's ducted or
ductless
at this case we're just looking at what
is it you're using
and an important part of this also is
just making sure that everybody knows to
be crystal clear this
is a chemical fume hood this is not a
biosafety cabinet
sometimes we say filtered people start
to think of bsc a biosafety cabinet
which is also hepa filtered for
biologicals
biologicals are not approved for use in
these hoods so we'll we'll double check
that on the chemical list
detection is everything declared it's
going to break through those filters
will
we be able to detect it will the filter
then be compatible with everything on
that list will we capture and contain
everything on that list and then lastly
life expectancy
which approval of that is really more up
to the end users
so on that point in the middle here
under the filtration section
is filter life now a little a little
internal speak sorry for this the m1
through m6 that's the hood size going
from a three footer up to an eight
footer
so for example an m4 four modules of
filtration that is a six foot wide hood
very common application in undergraduate
chemistry teaching labs for instance our
our most prevalent application and in
that case we're guaranteeing
for this customer 48 months filter life
very typical for what we see
again especially in teaching
applications if the hepa filters are
required we'll check that off
if the acid and ammonia pre-filter
options are required we'll check those
off individually or as shown here
together
it really depends on which chemicals
you're using and how we can maximize the
overall
neutron filter life and and your safety
so that's where the different
pre-filters that configurability we
talked about earlier
comes into play and then lastly based on
your specific application we will
fine-tune
the sensitivity of the breakthrough
detectors the solvent sensors and the
acid sensors
just making those appropriate for the
hazards or lack of hazard
of the chemicals you're using in that
hood
when we look at how we know all this i
mean how is it that
one company can can know all this
information we've been doing it for over
50 years we have our r d
lab over in france this is just a quick
picture of it
not to brag i just want to say this is
the level to which we go we've got
filtered storage cabinets ductless hoods
the filtration technology that labconco
uses on their filtered fume hoods
ceiling mounted fan filter units we know
filtration it's
what we do and then in the middle of
that back there is a little bubble our
test chamber i'll talk about that in a
moment
so when i talk about the go no go
the chemical list we have two different
lists the short list
is the no go list if you will and so
these are
chemicals that are not retained well by
any type of carbon filtration
and the best way to look at that is they
have low boiling points and low
molecular weights
therefore the gaseous at standard
temperature and pressure
and this list is basically what you
would expect hydrogen
all the noble gases methane ethane
carbon monoxide carbon dioxide nitrogen
monoxide you can read
sox nox and so these are the most common
gaseous chemicals now the good news is
they're not commonly used
in laboratories and some of these aren't
even hazardous not in the concentration
that would be released into the
laboratory but some of them most
certainly are
so if you're using any of these and
you're using them in higher volumes
it's probably a no go for a filtered
fume hood if you're using them in lower
volumes and i know higher and lower
that's always a difficult subject what
is high what is low what is a lot what
is a little what is medium
really depends on the frequency and the
quantity used i like to think of if it's
less than 200 milliliters a couple times
a month
i think we've got something i think
we've got a solution for you however the
real point here is
your environmental health and safety
officer definitely needs to be involved
because we're going to look at what will
happen
if those chemicals and again it's only
these chemicals would be released
into the lab how quickly would they be
diluted and removed from that lab
through the ventilation
again the good news is not commonly used
at all
and from our experience which is great
now
it's not just the chemicals it's also
which applications are not recommended
for a filtered fume hood i mean this
again this is the no go list right
so if you're a perchloric acid hood if
you're a radioisotope hood or acid
digestion type hood
definitely stick with your ducted hood
that's a special build a special part
anyhow it is not a candidate for
filtration
highly exothermic reactions one thing to
remember about filtered ductless
hoods is they do not remove heat from
the laboratory
so unlike a ducted hood which would it
would exhaust that heat right outside
filter hoods would not they would return
that heat right to the lab itself
again really not a problem for your
teaching uh
classes you're usually working with
smaller amounts you can absolutely use
bunsen burners and
in these hoods and and uh you know heat
your samples and whatnot
that's not a problem it's just that if
it's a really exothermic type reaction
especially if it generates a lot of
smoke also with that carbon filters do
not capture smoke
the optional hepa filters will capture
most smoke particles
i think there would still be a slight
smoke odor that would make it into the
lab though
so these are again things to consider on
the on the no go list
mercury not commonly used anymore
thankfully uh we can capture it really
well
problem is we can't detect it so we put
that on the no go list not down at the
tlv level required anyhow
and then anything that's high toxicity
or
basically immediately lethal those would
not be used
in a filtered fume hood
all right so then how do we know that
again getting down to the nitty gritty
here
so we have our our test bubble here in
the back of our laboratory in france
and we have our gcms machine and we have
gone through
hundreds of chemicals the most commonly
used chemicals in laboratories today
and those 700 plus chemicals represent
thousands of chemicals that'll respond
in a very similar manner to
molecular adsorption activated carbon
molecular absorption
and each one of those is tested at least
six or more
different concentrations and then each
one of those individual tests is
performed
twice just a minimum twice just to make
sure repeatability
so we're absolutely confident in our
capacity charts
and we know exactly how much we're going
to capture before
you're going to have uh greater than one
percent tlv
breakthrough on that filter and then
again they represent
thousands of different chemicals not
ivory chemical and so if you've got a
chemical that's not on our long list
we absolutely can review that and even
test that in this chamber in our
laboratory
so that's the test bubble that's the
gcms which is no great deal everybody
knows that it's just a very large
investment for us in
testing instruments but very much
required and so with that and with all
that testing
for now decades of testing we have
published our latest edition of the long
list
this is the chemical list that is uh now
over 60 pages long
of the chemicals that we know exactly
how much we can adsorb
and from that we'll know how long the
filter will last in your specific
application
maintenance casey talked about how in
his slide about eighteen hundred dollars
per year is the average operating cost
and that is replacing the filters
uh maintaining the the system make sure
it's working year after year
so it's not makeup air that's the great
thing because that's much more expensive
and so when it comes time to replace the
filter it's a very easy system we call
it a revolving system i wish it were a
crank handle and it would revolve on its
own it's not quite that simple
you do have to lift off the old filter
and put the new one on but not a big
deal it's 25 pounds the top of a six
foot ladder
at arm's length easy to do
and so the first thing you want to do
obviously is wear your standard ppe
gloves glasses if required in your lab a
lab coat too
absolutely not a problem there you do
not need to wear a respirator that is
not required
once the chemical is absorbed by the
carbon bed it is staying in there the
molecules are not coming out you could
lift the filter off accidentally drop it
on the floor from again the top of that
six foot ladder
and it won't but if you manage to break
it open we have it
compartmentalized so it wouldn't do that
but if you managed to break it open
somehow
you'd have carbon granules on the floor
it'd be quite a mess to sweep up no big
deal i've never done it in seven years
but again could be done
which you wouldn't have most importantly
is you wouldn't have liquid chemicals
you wouldn't have escape of molecules
they're all
in that carbon structure held there not
to be released
not under normal atmospheric conditions
anyhow
so you would then take the secondary
filter the one that's on top that safety
filter move it down to the primary
position
so it can start doing all the heavy
lifting as i call it step two you would
put a new secondary filter on top
and then step three you would package
the old primary filter
in the heavy poly bag and cardboard box
that the new filter came in
and send that off for environmental
disposal and there's a couple things
there
easiest and simplest most direct is out
for high temp incineration as hazardous
waste
the good news is carbon filters have a
lot of embedded energy
coconut shells activated coconut shells
is what we use as our
as our medium and the best on earth 15
000
square feet of surface area per gram all
of that is absorbed chemicals now you
have a lot of embedded energy that the
incinerator will put back up on the
electric grid
to the tune of around 78 kilowatts per
filter
i mean tremendous energy back up on the
grid from each one of these filters
and what comes out of that per epa
requirements you must have a 99.99
efficient incinerator is basically one
molecule
on a 10 000 gets out into the atmosphere
up the stack
there'll be some co2 there'll be some
water molecules but one in ten thousand
molecules of chemical make it
up versus ten thousand of every ten
thousand on the ducted hood
that you didn't use when you chose the
filtered hood
there is an option to do the t-clip or
tclp
and testing to make sure nothing leeches
from these filters and then the filters
can go out as
standard household waste that testing is
expensive though so you'd have to have a
lot of filters at the same time
and that's worked for some of our
customers just throwing that out there
as an option
and then obviously because now the fan
has also been removed and put back in
place the filters have been changed and
rotated
you need to re-certify that hood
filtered hoods just like ducted hoods
just like ductless hoods
should be annually re-certified and
that's through a third-party independent
company
with no stake in the game whatsoever
they come in they read face velocity
they make sure
you are running a safe hood at that
operating sash operating height that
you've
previously dictated
when you look at the absolute best
benefit of using filtered fume hoods it
is the 20-year operational carbon
footprint there is a
94 reduction and many thanks to
br plus a consulting engineers in boston
for doing the research here looking at
everything from transporting the carbon
to making the filters to incinerating
everything after the fact
to the metal work that goes into a
ducted hood versus a filter hood
same metal cabinets same lab concocture
but avoiding as you can see in in orange
and red
avoiding most of that electricity cost
and all of the gas
cost if you're in a zone that needs to
reheat you will see
a very large reduction in the carbon
footprint
so when it's safe to use for your
application which each application must
be blessed ahead of time
there is a tremendous environmental and
monetary
benefit to using the filtered fume hood
all right casey i think it is
back to you now thanks dan appreciate
you
providing that information so by now
you've learned what a
duct ductless fume hood is you've
learned about the
the benefits that it can have on on an
hvac system and
improving the efficiency of your of your
facility
and you've also learned about how um
how it is how it works and how it's safe
but now let's talk about what lab congo
has to offer in
in these types of uh these types of
products
first we have our echo which is a
full-size sphere hood
as i have mentioned before it comes in
multiple widths
it comes in it comes in configurations
that has
no windows it has side windows which is
what is shown here
and it also has side and back windows
that allows for a 360 degree
view of a hood interior which is great
for teaching off uh teaching
applications um we also have a smaller
more compact version of the echo in our
arrow
it has a shallower depth and also comes
in shower
shallower widths i mean it's also a
little bit shorter so it provides a
a good option for situations where
maybe you have a smaller footprint on in
your lab space or
you have reduced height in your ceiling
but still need a
a ductless new hood to operate your
applications inside of
there's also a an echo floor mounted
hood
which is very unique it's a one of a
kind fume hood and it's
and it is completely ductless and it
comes in
in multiple widths the same width as the
the echo bench top but also comes in
two additional depths because these
hoods are made to be
they're made to house large pieces of
equipment
so there are a lot of different sizes
in in shapes to make meet your uh
your application needs so that's what
live conco has to offer
um but i want to talk about the process
of
uh of going about getting a ductless
beam hood
the first step that needs to be done is
a an lpq or chemical assessment needs to
be filled out
as as i have mentioned and as ken has
mentioned this is
a very important step because it
determines the filtration compatibility
and the requirements there are certain
things that they can add that we can add
to
the the filtration column that can
maybe handle a certain part of your
application um
and ultimately make sure that uh the
longevity of these
filters and the safety of the operator
are insured
and next you need to identify the
appropriate hood and as i mentioned in
the previous slide
left conco has a variety of sizes of
fumes
so in identifying this you'll need to
take into account the size of equipment
that you're
that you may be using or the available
space that you have in your facility
and ensure that you are uh selecting the
proper fuel hood for for your
application
next most bench top fume hoods or all
all bench top
fume hoods need somewhere to sit and
that's where work surface would come in
place
something to take into account would be
a besides in
in a sink location if you're using water
and need to dispose of it
that would be something that you should
take into account um and then finally
to specify any service fixture
requirements that you have whether
that's water air gas electrical
vacuum uh pretty much anything that that
you need to put in your hood you need to
make sure that you're you're having
accounted for
so that's what we have for for the the
filtered fume hoods in
improving your labs green initiative um
i appreciate you taking the
time to listen to this presentation and
and i hope
i hope you can take something away from
us and i look forward to answering any
and all of your questions
thank you
thank you so much casey and ken for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so
now just click on the ask a question
box located on the far left of your
screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
our first question what is the average
lifespan for a set of filters
so the average lifespan it definitely
depends on the application but we found
that it's it
ranges from about two to five years uh
five being the max and
and two typically being the minimum so
it's in that range
is where they will will typically uh
fall in longevity
wonderful and the next question i have
what kind of spaces can filtered hoods
be utilized
uh in in pretty much any space uh
there's often times a a good uh good mix
of ducted and
duct less fume hoods for an individual
lap space but
but where these ones are more more
versatile or
are like modular labs or temporary
spaces if
if say you're moving into a new lab and
you have a
like a lab space outside that's in a
trailer or something that you you still
need to perform your
your applications and your procedures in
they
they are they're great for that as well
since they can be moved
into the permanent lab space after it's
finished
yeah i agree and i'll just jump in there
if you don't mind
the the swing space is is quite a need
right now with
uh renovations and new construction in
education facilities
and that's been a really good
application for these hoods also for
for exactly all the reasons casey just
said um so definitely think of them for
that and
if you've got an application that is
understood repeatable a certain level of
administrative controls
also help this is an engineered solution
but you do need
administrative controls when it comes to
a filtered hood
that's again why i think the education
marketplace higher ed is our number one
application
thank you so much for that okay the next
one i have coming in
says the dh3 have baffled in the back
and if not um how are we dealing with
the issue of airflow around
objects on the work surface
that's a that's a great question um and
one that needs to be asked asked
so no they do not have uh have baffles
in them and that's actually by design so
what does a baffle do is it draws
draws the air back away from the sash
and
and then up well that would actually
load the uh the filters uh
in the back in in risk the uh
the sensors going off uh before they're
they're able to and
ken can confirm that uh for me if you
can but
um to expand on this is that these hoods
even without the baffle have been put
through a modified
ashrae test uh in in that modified
ashrae test they use
um the i suppose isopropyl alcohol
in uh in and they still
have very low detection limits which is
showing that the hoods are still
containing even without the baffles
so yeah i'll jump in thanks casey
exactly right and
and even and so that's the modified so
testing in the field
because sf6 or um nox the typical tracer
gas is now
in place even though ashrae is changing
that
the sf6 nox they will go through the
filter and invalidate the test results
so
we've got that modified test procedure
for in the field at the factory the fume
wood manufacturers do a full and
complete 110 test
you know they attach a duct to the top
of it where the filters are
and exhaust that tracer gas so that it
doesn't invalidate the results
and correct we pass uh amazingly well
without the baffles in the back the
thing to remember here is instead of
trying to cram all that air through a 10
inch duct collar
somewhat centered in the top of the hood
the almost entire
surface of the ceiling of the fume hood
is the exhaust port
those multiple stacks i showed an
example of a six footer with four
filtration columns
those multiple stacks are columns and
modules of filtration
draw the air up certainly not laminar
flow not technically anyways the
reynolds number is not 2000 but
in a nearly linear fashion and we get a
much better flow coming in
and up and through and out so much more
reliable actually
than trying to put it all through a 10
inch duck collar which can be done and
you guys have solved that problem too
good question thank you
wonderful thanks so much for your
informative answers and thank you to the
audience for
and for asking these great questions the
next one i have
is what climate is your makeup air costs
how
calculated in
so that's that's also a good question
because that number will fluctuate based
on
where the the hoods are installed uh
what we have found is that
the uh so that calculation is done on
about
eight dollars per cfm and
uh what we have found the range is about
five dollars to about thirteen dollars
per uh
per cfm depending on where you're at so
um
it is a an estimate number but it's kind
of in the middle of what we've we've
uh we've seen to to kind of give as
accurate as a number as we could
wonderful the next one are the new
generation
filters compatible with the previous
units
sure i'll jump on that one there so
unfortunately the answer that is no
we to embrace a lot of the new
technology in the new approach we really
had to
sort of cut the umbilical cord if you
will so there is no backwards
compatibility to the existing filtered
fume hoods
we'll still make the filters to
obviously support those customers for
the life of those hoods out there
there's
thousands of them at this point but we
needed to really take a giant
technological leap forward
and that required that we could not hold
backwards compatibility we love to and
it's always a goal
on all of our new products however we
just couldn't do that in this case
thank you very good question
wonderful thank you again casey and ken
for your time today and your important
research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor la pronco
for underwriting today's educational
webcast before we go i'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time
of your registration this webcast can be
viewed on demand
lab roots will alert you via email when
it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until
then stay healthy and safe until next
time goodbye